it was an old factory in the middle of
nowhere long abandoned but still
standing in the past it had been filled
with workers but now nothing ran through
it besides the occasional wildlife one
july night in 1949 though four teenagers
decided it would be a good place to
explore the entrance to the factory was
a large old-fashioned looking wooden
door that was locked tightly shot the
teens looked around for another way in
but couldn't find one what they did find
though was an old iron lockbox after
some effort they managed to get the box
open and found a ring of 12 old rusted
steel keys sitting inside would these
old keys open the wooden door would they
find something inside that would make
their night of breaking and entering
worth it if only they knew that by
unlocking the door all they would find
was true horror because they had just
found scp-000
better known as the 12 keys and the door
not long after the local sheriff
received a call from three of the panic
teams they explained that while trying
to get into the factory one of their
friends had gone missing the local
authorities were quickly deployed taking
the three teens into custody and
beginning a full search of the factory
grounds the searching sheriff's
department officers did eventually
manage to find a clue as to what
happened to the missing teen but it
wasn't a good sign it was their severed
hand and even more disturbing is that it
wasn't discovered outside the factory no
it was found over eight kilometers away
soon other body parts were also found
some as far as 32 kilometers away but
how could the parts of the dead
teenager's body have been scattered so
quickly and so far from each other when
the surviving teens were interrogated
they all repeated the same wild story
the now dead teen had taken one of the
keys out of the old box they had found
and used it to unlock the strange
old-fashioned wooden door that led into
the factory they opened the door and
stepped inside and the moment they did
they were immediately torn into pieces
that suddenly vanished these were no
ordinary keys and this was no ordinary
door it was clear this was a job for the
scp foundation an scp agent was deployed
to the site to begin investigating this
anomaly after getting the keys from
local authorities the agent brought in a
group of 12 d-class personnel to test
them one for each key and it soon became
clear that there was one effect that was
common ten of the keys seemed to cause
an effect that was completely
unsurvivable upon trying the key in the
door the test subject was immediately
torn apart just like the unfortunate
teenager while one key caused the body
parts to be scattered in the immediate
vicinity all the others seemed to vanish
into thin air but it was the other two
keys that proved to be of even greater
interest to the foundation unlike with
all the other tests the d-class using
the key designated
scp-004-7 was able to enter the door and
return completely unharmed but the
d-class using scp-004-2
was a different story physically he
returned unharmed but he seemed barely
able to stagger out of the room he
collapsed and then began trying to claw
his eyes out in panic and terror he was
quickly restrained and interrogated but
he wasn't coherent enough to give the
foundation any idea of what lurked
behind the door the first d-class to
enter using scp-004-7
the one who returned intact insane only
said that it was a massive room inside
far bigger than the building appeared
from the outside it was determined that
the use of this key was safe enough for
further testing the door was open again
using the same key and the foundation
researchers propped it open so that an
armed team could go inside and hopefully
come out a brief exploration of the
massive room showed some clear anomalous
properties not only was the room
impossible to measure and possibly
limitless in size it also seemed
impossible to shine any light in the
room beyond the entry and the people
inside were the only objects that could
be felt or illuminated whatever this
room was it was keeping its secrets it
was clear the site needed to be locked
down all the initial witnesses who knew
too much were terminated the foundation
was a little more trigger-happy with
terminations in the 40s and the site was
quickly locked down under the auspices
of being dangerous due to unexploded
ordinances fences were placed around the
site so that there would be no more
teenage explorations the records are
spotty and incomplete but whatever
happened behind those doors during the
initial testing between 1949 and 1950
the foundation decided it had learned
enough the space-time anomalies at play
inside of scp-004 were deemed too
dangerous to explore further and the
site was sealed off with all testing
suspended whatever was lurking behind
those doors it would keep its secrets
and the site seemed easy to secure and
contain but this was far from the end of
scp-004
and 50 years later it made its presence
known again it was another july night
many decades after the unfortunate
teenager first opened the doors to
scp-004
only a few pieces of their body had been
found but suddenly the rest of the
corpse appeared exactly where they had
last been seen outside the old wooden
door even odder was the fact that even
though the subject had died many years
ago their body was still fresh as if
they had been killed that same day and
this wouldn't be the only sudden
reappearance two days later a second
body missing parts appeared in front of
the door this was quickly identified as
one of the original 12 test subjects who
opened the door foundation scientists
were once again sent to the site to
explore the space-time anomalies and it
was becoming clear that what went inside
the door didn't stay there it seemed
like it went somewhere that didn't exist
on the same plane as our reality and if
it could be understood it could be used
on march 21 1999 the foundation began
establishing a site inside of scp-004
but not for testing or research purposes
nuclear weapons around the world were
proliferating fast and evidence was
mounting that world war 3 could happen
soon the foundation needed a site that
could survive anything and the
mysterious room opened by the rusted
keys seemed like it could be their
salvation supplies would go in the room
and would be preserved there
indefinitely safe from even nuclear
annihilation but getting the site set up
would pose its own challenges now dubs
site-62 the facility was soon expanded
to house certain scps as well in
addition to a supercomputer to house all
foundation data this would make it
another invaluable backup in the event
of an end of the world event that
necessitated a reboot the site was
completed over the next year during
which time they added high-tech
containment units that could hold even
the most dangerous scp specimens
entering and exiting the facility seemed
to pose a risk to those working on it
though time no longer behaved like it
should even when using the one safe key
people would spend weeks in the site
then exit claiming they'd only been
there a few days it was highly
unpredictable
and the foundation determined that it
would be better to eliminate this x
factor all personnel working at site-62
would now live on site permanently with
their families being told that they had
died in an accident it was august 18
2003 when the united states and canada
were hit with a massive power outage
knocking out power to many of the
northeast's biggest population centers
while the scp foundation has backups on
every site multiple generators failed
and it was 53 minutes before power could
be restored during that time those
inside the mysterious room were plunged
into total darkness and it soon became
clear
they weren't alone
in the darkened room the personnel
reported feeling that they were
surrounded by people that shouldn't be
there and creatures that shouldn't exist
while they couldn't see anything and
nothing touched them they were adamant
that something was lurking in the room
and likely had been for a very long time
it seemed the limited source of light
may be the only thing keeping these
entities whatever they are at bay when
testing had resumed on scp-004 after the
bodies had reappeared outside the door
the foundation decided to start
exploring the effects of scp-004-12
as well what about this key caused such
psychological horror that the subjects
would try to tear out their own eyes
this key seemed to drive them insane and
of the 16 subjects only four were still
alive for any length of time after their
return most remained in a catatonic
state but one was given extensive
therapy and regained the ability to
communicate which allowed him to give
the foundation their best picture yet of
what lurked inside the room while the
d-class personnel was still severely
affected by his time in the room and
suffered near total amnesia he did
remember a few things he remembered deep
terror and memories being forced into
his mind that made no sense as if they
were artificially implanted and he
remembered not being alone he described
a massive green being large enough that
he couldn't see where it began and where
it ended the foundation didn't know what
it was either but what they did know for
certain is that when 10 of these keys
are used the door is open to a dimension
where the laws of physics are so
different that it is completely
unsurvivable studies are ongoing as to
what makes this effect so fatal and if
there is a way to survive it but no
answers have been found and with only
three bodies of victims recovered so far
there is little evidence but one object
found on site is of additional interest
discovered roughly a year after the
initial anomaly in a manager's office on
the factory grounds
scp-004-14 seems to be a miniature
version of the anomaly it's a large box
made out of wood and it is the only
other object opened by the one safe key
as well as five of the other keys that
lead to death when used on the main door
and this box has unusual properties as
well it opens automatically and much
like
scp-004's room it seems to be much
larger on the inside than the outside it
is possible to come in and out safely
but once the box is locked again it is a
different story objects placed in the
box don't seem to affect its weight and
when the box is closed and locked they
vanish completely unlike the main room
nothing that's gone inside and locked in
has ever been recovered this includes
living beings few answers have been
found out about where they go and it's
possible the box could be used to
dispose of specimens deemed to be too
dangerous but with no answers about
where they go and when they might come
back this may be too risky because
scp-004 is fixed in place special
containment procedures focus on making
sure it stays that way it is strictly
forbidden to take any of the other keys
through the door for fear of losing them
or causing it to react in an
unpredictable way if the side should be
breached or anything contained in
site-62 manages to escape containment
the foundation is ready to activate the
on-site warhead only employees with
level one clearance can access the site
and only level fours and above can use
the keys with all knowing that any
attempt to remove the keys from the site
will result in immediate termination for
now
scp-004 remains fenced off with only
select experiments continuing as the
foundation tries to unravel its
mysteries but whatever lurks behind that
wooden door it keeps its secrets well
now for another location that doesn't
obey the laws of physics check out
scp-354 the red pool or watch
scp-823 carnival of horrors for another
seemingly normal location with
unexpected dangers